going back to you know the fight that
you got coming up right now between you
and um Dustin uh it's interesting
because you know Dustin you know 28
fights in UFC you've had five right and
you've come in and you fought everybody
you know you came in you know Dan hooker
you have the fight you know uh Dustin
goes 25 minutes with him you go two and
a half minutes with them okay so that's
a comparison that we got to make in the
market then you go with Charles uh I
think Charles comes after that right
Charles comes after that you almost won
that one I mean it was like this right
uh then you're going with you know
Justin and that's fight of the night
fight of the Year everyone's gone the
fight of the year it was insane of a
fight it's one of those fights that
you'll watch regularly because it
doesn't get old when you watch that
fight the kicks the left leg the story
you're kicking he's kicking you're
kicking he's getting like nobody wants
to stop kicking it was a it was like a
two minute thing you just go like this
is insane with this guy I couldn't walk
for like six weeks
[Music]
no I don't know if you've seen this with
these kids because he's known Justin's
known that he's gonna he's Relentless
about throwing these kicks again it's
constant yeah but he's also going back
and forth back and forth anyways then
you have your you know last
the last fight you have with uh uh Tony
you know knockout of the year do you
mean the kicker around the world yeah
man it's just that was a slow motion of
his face yeah I mean everyone's seen
that one that took place and by the way
Class Act you know the way it was spoken
in announced coming up to Dustin so
this this me meet up with Dustin you
know we've heard and we've seen
everything between you know what's been
said and what he said and what you said
and Ariel is asking you about him and
I'm not thinking about fighting him
because at the time he was talking about
retirement and you know and you said
you've never used those words retirement
I'm not thinking about retirement he was
so that's why I was thinking about
fighting somebody else you know and you
know for for him to approach you at a
fight and then you know Cormier puts the
two of you guys down it was a great
conversation a full 14-minute
conversation was classic because uh he's
trying to steer it apart and you can
tell Dustin was upset and you're trying
to just stay poised and calm but he's
saying what he's saying to you and you
know shots are being fired and then now
some people are saying well these guys
are hugging they're friends what is it
is it act do they hate each other do
they want is this going to be a real
fight or are we going to see like uh too
friendly of a fight so today with you
know what the market has seen and what's
really going on where are you at with
this fight coming up it's the you know a
fight everyone's looking forward to what
are you thinking about with is it really
a fight that there's going to be
animosity to fight or is it just two
professionals getting in the ring to
fight I think the overarching theme is
is it's two professionals getting in and
getting in there to fight
um you know I think you know you talk
about the the hug like that was that was
pre that was pre-beef you know that was
me and me and Dustin sat there for an
hour before weigh-ins just kind of
talking about everything he's trying my
groove life ring on because he was
wearing a silicone ring I'm like hey
these are the best but I'll send you
some blah blah blah we're talking about
our kids we're talking about our wives
we're talking about you know what we do
um and there was a lot of mutual respect
and then right after that fight that was
when he the the illustrious hey if they
want me to fight Chandler I'd rather
just go sell hot sauce so then there was
kind of the you know the just pushing me
aside so I'm like okay wait a second
okay I thought we were cool
and I didn't you know take that into I
don't know I didn't didn't really take
it too personally
um because at that point I knew I
probably wasn't going to fight Dustin
next or maybe I was who knew at that at
that point in time and then you know
since then I have done some interviews
where I'm like you know I'm I'm kind of
I've taken this I've had a debut of the
year in 2021 I had knockout of the year
or the year uh fight of the year in 2021
I might have knockout of the year in
2022 you know so I'm continuing to rise
and rise and rise and Dustin was talking
about going to 170 talking about
fighting Diaz which we all know what
that means it's not exactly like you're
trying to stay on the trajectory to win
the title he did say retirement so I did
take the Liberty to maybe maybe it was a
little bit disrespectful to say I'm not
even thinking about Dustin and there was
one moment where I actually did forget
Dustin's name because I think I had
pushed his name out of my my top five of
who I would fight because I thought he
was moving up to 170 or whatnot so maybe
it was a little bit subconscious on
accident
and he took you know he took a fence to
that so they're then you know the the
video of us at the the fight obviously
he he wanted to say his piece which I
respect you know he doesn't need to
tweet me you know even though he has
tweeted me and then I roasted him with
an awesome Tweet back which he even said
Chandler roasted me because Diamond at
the end yeah is that the one you're
talking about no it was actually it was
it was actually no it was Michael we
don't need to get into it it was great
he called me Michael Chandler you know
so I have a chin right and then and I
said and I said speaking of or speaking
of chins Michael Johnson fights tonight
the last time Dustin Poirier fought
Michael Johnson was this date in Hidalgo
Texas and he knocked out Dustin Poirier
you know like and I used hashtag chin
history but then he came back with I
don't even know what to say that's
awesome you know got you so there was
even that kind of mutual that's cool
that's the kind of stuff that's how I
would respond as well if he did that to
me I'd be like okay what do I say here
like let him keep going okay
so there's there's that you know I think
there's a mutual respect I think him and
I are very similar in a lot of ways I
think our values are are very similar I
think we we fight for our families we
fight for our Legacy and we we you know
we take the sport you basically stand up
with this guy
I didn't know I've been known to do some
staying yeah I mean I think I can knock
him out I think he can knock me out I
think so I think we both have the
confidence there on the on the on the
feet
um I think my wrestling is better I
think my grappling is better so I'm
honestly I think I I always go in there
with the game plan of mixing up and
keeping them guessing yeah I haven't
done a great job of that in the UFC thus
far
um but it's bowed me well with the the
fans in my platform so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]